we're going to do in this video is
review the notion of composite functions
and then build some skills recognizing
how functions can actually be composed
if you've never heard of the term
composite functions or if the first few
minutes of this video look unfamiliar to
you i encourage you to watch the algebra
videos on composite functions on khan
academy the goal of this one is to
really be a little bit of a practice
before we get into some skills that are
necessary in calculus in particular the
chain rule so let's just review what a
composite function is
so let's say
that i have
let's say that i have f of x
f of x being equal to 1 plus x
and let's say that we have g of x
is equal to
let's say g of x is equal to cosine
of x
so what would
f of g of x b
f
of
g of x and i encourage you to pause this
video and try to work it out on your own
well one way to think about it is the
input into f of x is no longer x it is g
of x so everywhere where we see an x in
the definition of f of x we would
replace with the g of x so this is going
to be equal to
this is going to be equal to
1 plus instead of the input being x the
input is g of x so the output is 1 plus
g of x
and g of x of course is cosine of x so
instead of writing g of x there i could
write
cosine
of x
and one way to visualize this is i'm
going putting my x into g of x first
so x goes into the function
g
and it outputs g of x
and then we're going to take that output
g of x and then input it into f of x or
input it into the function f i should
say
we input into the function f
and that is going to output
f of whatever the input was and the
input is g of x
g of x so now with that review out of
the way let's see if we can go the other
way around let's see if we can look at
some type of a function definition and
say hey can we express that as a as a
composition of other functions
so let's start with let's say
that i have
a g of x
is equal to cosine
of
sine
of x
plus 1.
and
i also want to state there's oftentimes
more than one way to compose a or to
construct a function based on the
composition of other ones but with that
said pause this video and say hey can i
express g of x as a composition of two
other functions let's see an f and an h
of x
so there's a couple of ways that you
could think about it you could say all
right let's see i have this sine of x
right over here
so what if i called that an f of x so
let's say i call that
well let me actually let me use a
different variable so we don't get
confused here let me use let me call
this u
of x the sine of x right over there so
this would be cosine of u of x plus one
and so if we then divided if we then
defined another function
as v of x
being equal to
cosine of whatever its input is
plus one
well then this looks like the
composition of v and u of x instead of v
of x if we did v of u of x then this
would be cosine of u of x plus 1. let me
write that down
so that if we wrote v of
u of x
which is sine of x if we did v of u of x
that is going to be equal to
cosine
of instead of an x plus 1 is going to be
a u of x plus 1
and u of x let me write this here u of x
is equal to sine of x
that's how we've set this up so we could
either write cosine of u of x plus 1 or
cosine of sine of x plus 1 which was
exactly what we had before
and so this function g of x if we say u
of x is equal to sine of x
if we say u of x is equal to sine of x
and v of x is equal to cosine of x plus
then we could write g of x as the
composition of these two functions
now you could even make it a composition
of three functions we could keep u of x
to be equal to sine of x we could define
let's say a
w of x to be equal to x plus one
and so then let's think about it w
of x
w of u of x i should say
w of
u
let's do the same color
w
of u of x
is going to be equal to
now my input is no longer x it's a u of
x so it's going to be a u of x plus 1
or just sine of x plus 1.
so that's sine
of x plus 1. and then if we define a
third function
let's say let's see i'll call it let's
call it h i'm running out of variables
well there are a lot of letters left so
if i say h of x is just equal to the
cosine of whatever i input so it's equal
to the cosine of x
well then h of w of u of x is going to
be g of x let me write that down h of
w
of
u of x
is going to be equal to
remember h of x takes the cosine of
whatever its input is so it's going to
take the cosine
now its input is w of u of x we already
figured out w of u of x is going to be
this business so it's going to be
sine
of x
plus 1.
where the u of x is sine of x but then
we input that into w so we got sine of x
plus 1 and then we inputted that into h
to get cosine of that which is our
original expression which is equal to
g of x so the whole point here is to
appreciate
how to recognize compositions of
functions
now i want to stress it's not always
going to be a composition of a function
for example if i have some function
let me just clear this out if i had some
function
f of x
is equal to
cosine of x
times sine of x
i it would be hard to exp to express
this as a composition of functions but i
can represent it as the product of
functions for example i could say cosine
of x i could say u of x is equal to
cosine of x
and i could say v of x is a different
color
i could say
v of x is equal to sine of x and so here
f of x wouldn't be the composition of u
and v it would be the product f of x is
equal to
u of x
times v of x
v of x if we were to take the
composition if we were to say
u
of
v of x pause the video think about what
that is and that's a little bit of
review
well this is going to be
i take the u of x
takes the cosine of whatever is input
and now the input is v of x which would
be sine of x
sine of x
and then if you did v of u of x well
that'd be the other way around it would
be sine of cosine of x but anyway this
is once again just to help us recognize
hey do i when i look at an expression or
a function definition am i looking at
products of functions am i looking at
compositions of functions sometimes
you're looking at products of
compositions or quotients of
compositions all sorts of different
combinations of how you can put
functions together to create new
functions